[Music]
so
we just come off of fourth of july
weekend
independence day and of course there's
all this
rhetoric and the hate out there floating
around that
the american dream is dead america is
horrible i'm ashamed of america and all
these people with their
dissatisfactions taken out on the
country that they
live in and then
you meet edgar and floor man you come
here from the philippines
with 20 in his pocket 19 years ago
four years and 10 months ago he decided
they were going to get out of debt
and while they were doing that they were
going to keep investing because it was
baby steps four five and six and doing
it properly the way he's supposed to
paying off his house and simultaneously
investing
and we meet him four years and ten
months later and he
has seven hundred thousand as mutual
funds owns a four hundred thousand
dollar paid for
house is one hundred percent debt
free and is a millionaire somehow that
doesn't sound to me like the american
dream is dead
i think what's dead are people's brains
i'm kind of at a loss for words man just
we went out there during the break and
got to
high five them and hugged them and
there's tears of
emancipation there's tears of
peace there's tears of we worked really
we outworked everybody
man they did we outworked you we went to
they both of them are highly educated
they got hard
degrees like nursing degree and a
medical technology degree
and they got education they worked their
butts off and then they just got home
and said hey we're gonna hit the gas
and they brought their kids along for
the ride so their kids had a ringside
seat to what hard work looks like what
freedom looks like what hey we're all
contributing looks like
it just goes back to there's no living
the american dream looks like
it's it's it's hard work we came here
from the philippines and
to to live in the land of opportunity
and by god we're going to get our
opportunity
we're going to make we're not going to
you know i didn't hear him say
you know somebody held us back i didn't
hear any uh isms
i didn't hear anything well i i
guarantee you they were i
guarantee you i'll guarantee you many
people mistreated them along the way
and they leaned on each other they
leaned on their and their friends
friends have tears running down their
face they've got community they've got
people in their lives and we are all in
together
and now you got i just can't get over
there's a formula here for you guys out
there listening okay it's not just
bashing those that are bashing america
which is that's okay i'll i'll put that
in there gladly okay
because you need to be smacked sideways
but just aside from that
the formula is that you get what you
sign up for
as a man thinketh in his heart so is he
what you can conceive and believe you
can achieve and so if you say
america's gone bad there's systemic
racism there's systemic
sexism there's systemic economic
uh inequality disparity there's systemic
everything
and so i can't get ahead
but then there's edgar right who says
shut up yeah i'm gonna go with his life
with his life he says no
that's not how this is going to happen
it's not how it works yes all of those
isms are out there
and there are jerks that hold people
back because of whatever
yeah there are people that think that
i'm not intelligent because i have a
southern accent
this is how stupid our culture is okay
um i mean this is
it's for there are jerks that will hold
you back and anything all the time
whatever you can't be on this show
because you're conservative you can't be
on this show because you're liberal you
can't do that you can't do this you
can't do that
can't can't can't can't can't can't
can't
and then there's edgar there's edgar who
says
if you believe we're doing it yeah i
believe
that if i go do this that this is going
to be the result and based on his belief
he turns up the heat and then he gets
some friends in his life
and they turn it up on each other and
they they're gay they're competing
friendly hey where's oscar hey he's
working a second job hey oscar rode
down here with us from las vegas and
brenda
yeah they came along for the ride
because they're in it with us
yeah we're in it to win it baby and
there's no
there's there was no victim thing
there's no anything there's no america's
dead
oh i came here and it was all a lie yeah
that that
nothing what happened there's just
that's not how i experienced it well
then maybe you need to change your
belief
or change your community or change who
you're
who you're listening to or who it is
that you're going to
because your belief causes your you know
causes your actions
yeah his belief caused him to work a
hundred
hours a week what what one of the
millionaires truest in psychology is
what you what you believe you will see
everywhere yep what you ex what you want
to go see what you
envision will be everywhere and that
doesn't mean that
like you said it doesn't mean that there
isn't evil and ugly and hatred it's
everywhere
it's everywhere and then you can decide
i'm going to wake up tomorrow and i'm
going to look as hard as just like when
i go outside in my yard and there's no
lights out there
i can be still for a minute and i can
see the little pinpricks
of light in those stars across the dark
i can go see the light i'm going to go
find it
and i'm going to keep showing up and
keep showing up i'm going to take my
friends with me and they're going to
take me with them
and like i it's rare that i'm sitting
here inspired on this show
and it happened today because i got to
watch what it looks like when somebody
says
20 bucks in an opportunity i'm in yeah
i'm in
man man it put me in coach he changed it
i forget coach i'm just heading out on
the field
right i'm headed on the field i when i
coached high school i don't need
permission i had a player that would
just head out and i you know what i
wanted i wanted that guy on the court
because he i i'll take this last shot
and he
that kind of kid also practiced his butt
off and also worked it was a great
teammate
but it's the kids saying oh i'm in on
this last play yeah
i'm in man i'm your guy and that's the
guy i want man i'm your guy you can't
keep me out
you're not gonna hold me back you're not
gonna tell me no man
and you know sometimes it takes 20 years
sometimes it takes 20 months sometimes
it takes four years and 10 months
and um and and then you've not only
changed your life
your current present circumstances but
you've not only changed your retirement
you've not only changed the way you age
out you've not only changed those kids
lives
but you literally not metaphorically
you literally really have that's what
that means
changed your family tree yeah because
you you we're talking that 12 year old
out there that that kid is
she's not she's way beyond 12. she's
going to take
the combined computational brain power
of those two incredible parents
plus their work ethic that they showed
her and taught her and expected of her
and held her account before
and she's going to take that to a
university that's going to honor it or
into the workplace that's going to honor
it and there will be
you know what i mean no the sky's the
limit there is no rockets rocket fuel
i'm going to be really kind to her
because i'm probably working for her
someday dave
my goodness it's incredible it's
incredible
that's true you probably should be it's
incredible
it's it's if we can experience
what i call the both and if you can hold
your childhood trauma your
pain the the very realisms that exist
and then open your eyes in the morning
and say
what am i going to do in spot in spite
of that what am i going to do
what am i going to be what am i going to
do and you've got to
i've always i've worked with people who
are you just forget all that and you
just go
that's not that's dumb no and then i've
got other folks who say i can't do
anything i'm stuck here
yeah right it's both not not saying it's
both ends it doesn't exist
it's both in we're not in denial this is
not repression
this is yeah it's there and and it's
both in go do it anyway get up and go
man
get a group of people can't do it by
yourself get a group of people that's
going to show up and drive across the
country with you go be edgar
oh my gosh you know go be edgar when you
grow up man
i mean go be floor when you grow up yes
that's what you want to be
and that's that's you know i'm going to
get t-shirts
t-shirts and let me just tell you you
don't need to be out there if you're
that guy
saying america's dead
you don't need to be doing that nope
because it's factually
incorrect incorrect it's intellectually
dishonest
and you're a jerk you do it
so on top of that uh i'm getting my team
floor and edgar shirts today
there we go